oh yeah it's that time you're gonna love
this time of year so exciting it's time
for me to give you guys my top ten
favorite movies of 2014 and remember
this is my very subjective and biased
list of my top 10 favorite movies of
2014 some of the movies on this list do
not have the strongest performances some
of the movies on this list are not shot
perfectly but these are the top 10
movies in 2014 that made me go you know
what hell yeah that movie thank you in
mind these aren't reviews of the movies
I already did my reviews I'll put
annotations over here for each movie
that makes my list so you can go to
click on it and see the reviews well you
agree with all of this list no will you
agree with some of it I like to think so
are you gonna have some fun here let's
hope so
all right disclaimers have been
disclaims let's start having some fun
here starting off our list is guardians
of the galaxy they source the movie that
made me go you know I think I'm
officially gonna watch anything that
Marvel Studios does because they're on a
roll they took a bunch of misfits that
no one had heard about from a comic but
no one had read and made it a pretty
kick-ass sci-fi movie that reminded me
of like I said my review star track
meets star wars went splat as a fan of
both of those franchises how could I say
no
next we have John wick John wick was the
kick-ass hitman movie I've wanted to see
for years so happens that got Keanu
Reeves in the lead role and we all have
seen that dude because he's just a fun
guy not only was John wick a kick-ass
character in a kick-ass movie but I love
the world they built in this movie big
comic book fan I looked at it I'm like
this is a comic book world Keanu Reeves
is kicking ass at 50 that's just that
should be on the list just for that so
happens the movie coming in at number
eight we have gun girl gone girl was the
type of investigative whodunit type
movie that I liked watching because it
takes you along with it you're not
smarter than the cops and the people in
it you just have the evidence to go on
that they have really hard to talk about
this movie and not spoil anything in the
movies fact is go see it the movie is a
little long for sure but it's intriguing
as and there's one thing you want
in a movie like this its intrigue it's
just what you need it's what this movie
has number 17 coming in at number 7
that's right Keanu Reeves is not the
only yesteryear action star who's still
getting working kicking ass Tom Cruise
is too in the edge of tomorrow or
I repeat whatever it's called now this
movie is why I look forward to summer
movies because once in a while you can
get that movie that's a kickass movie
that gives you something new makes you
go you know what yeah originality in an
action movie in an action movie based on
the same day repeating over and over and
over again which doesn't sound original
but telling you it is because admit it
when you watch the Groundhog Day you
were like I hope they do an action movie
like that I really hope they do one day
and the Dead Sea number-6 surprised me
it surprised me because when I first saw
the movie I was like this is gonna be in
my top three easy where's that it's in
number six which ain't nothing's still
in my top ten list at number six but the
movie that would be How to Train Your
Dragon 2 I love this movie this was the
animation and let me go you know what
they still make animations like that
till I saw this movie till I saw How to
Train Your Dragon 2 I was like where are
the animations like The Lion King where
are the animations that can resonate
with kids and adults where are the ones
that speak to adulthood and show
coming-of-age but yet they entertain
kids but still hit adults to the core I
swear to God I was like they don't do
that anymore and I saw how to train your
dragon to it I was like nope it's still
alive I love how to train your dragon -
coming in at number 5 is our first
official creeper on the list that would
be Nightcrawler this was a movie I was
like Gyllenhaal you're a great actor and
this is your transformation role you're
not even on screen this weird creep is
he wanted to be the best at his job and
he would do anything to do that it's
cool seeing his evolution in the movie
you're seeing a predator evolve in the
movie Nightcrawler that's what this is
it's a really good look at it and it's a
really great movie not gonna lie to you
guys every year I do a top 10 list the
top 3 movies I shuffle around so many
times like I don't know which will one
two three no three two one oh two one
three this year it was the top four
making the top four so difficult I
shuffle them around every which way if I
can give them all a four-way tie I would
but I can't I gotta put them in the
order and this is the order for number
four is dawn of the Planet of the Apes
this movie was great you've seen the
first act of this movie you think you
know where it's gonna go you don't you
don't know anything Caesars great Andy
Serkis kills it in this movie it's an
action movie but it's a movie with heart
it's a movie about civilization it's a
political movie this is next-level
in the Apes franchise it makes me look
forward to
third one I want to have my Planet of
the Apes trilogy if they can keep the
movies going this good I'll take seven
eight nine movies
number three is among my top tier Marvel
movies at this point Captain America the
Winter Soldier this showed me that
Marvel movies they give me comic book
movies that are actually really
intriguing spy movies and espionage
movies this movie did everything right
they made Captain America badass you
have antitrust with shields they made
Black Widow a really good character and
it was a kick-ass movie to boot it was
that movie rose like I haven't felt this
good about a Marvel movie since I walked
out of Iron Man 1 the first time I just
imagined at this point Civil War it's
just kidding
we're at the top two guys this is it
this is zero hour coming in at number
two is x-men Days of Future past it's
like this I love the x-men movies and
the x-men movies had some trips along
the way this was what the x-men movies
needed to bring up back on course the
director of the original first two x-men
movies putting it back giving us the
best of both worlds you have the old
cast you have the new cast from x-men
first class this is one of those movies
I bought it when he came out on blu-ray
watched it again liked it more the
second time and I loved it the first
time uses some tough shoes to fill for
Apocalypse but yeah if they can do it
here it is guys number one my favorite
movie of 2014
drumroll it's gonna be no other movie in
hit me to the core like this movie did
this movie stabbed a spike in my heart
was like boom yeah you're gonna think
about this every day until you do your
top 10 list cuz I've thought about this
movie every day until I'm doing this
letter I'll still think about it after
this list is done oh my god what not to
like about this movie this is an intense
movie it's an ambitious movie JK Simmons
is great miles teller I see him now in a
completely new light can you tell I like
movies about people just trying their
best to be the best possible at their
craft and apparently a dick who throws
chairs at them if they're not or they
are but he wants them to be better I
can't say anything new about whiplash
that I haven't already said in my review
I mean I speak this movie's praises to
everybody I talk about this movie too
apparently it takes JK Simmons throwing
chairs at students and being a complete
dick to take out the group of mutants
from the past in the future alright guys
and that concludes my list of my top 10
favorite movies of 2014 now if you don't
agree with my list perfectly fine now
what you can do one of two things here
you can either be like where's this
movie where's that movie or or or you
tell me in the comment section what your
top 10 favorite movies of 2014 are and
you can join in this fun I'm really
curious to hear at those so guys what
are your top 10 favorite movies of 2014
whatever they are comment below let me
know thank you guys for a kick-ass year
All Things Considered 2014 has some
shitty movies for sure but I had some
really good ones and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more